[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast if
you could just take a quick second and
hit subscribe I would appreciate it very
much uh the thumbs up also helps today
on the show is Christina Lopez she is a
life coach a spiritual teacher she is an
author and she has a background in
neuropediatrics so she has a really good
awareness for the mind the body the
connection and and really how to process
things I've been watching her on YouTube
for a long time and she has a lot of
great content she really explains how
when she had her Spiritual Awakening
that it was something that she tried to
justify from this clinical mind of like
okay I'm having a psychotic breakdown
and so she explains that story uh really
well you know her background is is is
science and it's like the Practical the
accessible the tangible and she was
broken open into this spiritual world of
so much more information than what we
can see so the first thing I asked her
to do is is to explain what is spiritual
I I truly like think this is one of the
one of the best episodes I have done
about spirituality and about the process
and the and the and the way that we
experience it and what we go through
it's super comprehensive super
accessible
and I've watched and read a lot of lot
of stuff when it comes to spirituality
and the process and the and I've
experienced a lot but I learned a lot
today you know if I can come away with
even like one thing that I've never
heard I always feel like that was really
cool and interesting I'm so grateful for
that experience but there was many
things today Christina is just uh a
really helpful teacher and so anyway I
hope you love this episode as much as I
did I I I I think it's going to be super
helpful for a lot of people in their in
their Journey so please let me know what
you think in the comments enjoy the
episode if you've been following me a
while you know that I've been drinking
ag1 all all year no matter where I go or
what I do if I'm at the racetrack if I'm
in Europe for six weeks no matter what
I'm drinking ag1 every single morning
when I started drinking ag1 daily what I
noticed was that my gut health improved
I could eat so many different foods
without it bothering me my skin has
gotten better my hair is healthier so
many functions that everybody wants to
get better got better it's so awesome
and I've been bragging about it so much
that my friends and my family have also
started taking it and they love it as
well ag1 is the supplement that I trust
to support my body's daily needs and
that's why we have been partners for so
long if you want to take ownership of
your health it starts with ag1 try ag1
and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 plus five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase go to
drink a1.com pretty intense that's drink
a1.com pretty intense check it out have
you been in Portugal for a long time I
was raised in Portugal my parents are
Portuguese and so I have dual
citizenship um but I was in the US for
many many years and then I came back in
2014 so I've been living here since 2014
I was in New York City I've been looking
into like how to get a passport an EU
passport and Portugal is actually top of
the list for like the easiest if you
want to if you don't have any
descendants which I found I have some
sisly blood in me Co on my dad's side so
I was like I'm going to try that route
but Portugal is like one of the easiest
countries to to get a passport but one
of the tricks is I read like The the
fine print of the few things you had to
do and one of them is and you have to be
able to take a test in Portuguese oh
really and I was like oh that would be
hard you better start learning
now I'll have to get your advice on
where to go in Portugal then because
it's totally happening it just oh it's
amazing it's amazing do I go Southern or
more nor isn't like the beach beach
places more Southern and then go
everywhere it's such a small country oh
literally rent a car and just go
everywhere but yeah South there are
beautiful beaches literally everywhere
it's not just the South The South The
Algarve region is very crowded in the
summer but it's got beautiful stretches
of beach but there's just oh my God
there's so many beaches and just so much
to see you got to come to Lisbon Lisbon
amazing uh there's so much I'd love it
and then I might pair that with like
Morocco o that's good like San
Sebastian
Morocco Portugal that feels like a good
Loop right that's an amazing loom yeah I
just recently saw it was on Instagram it
was like maybe it's I don't know cond
Nast or something like that a Travelers
Journal kind of thing and it said that
the number one food city is San
Sebastian
oh that's have you been there in Spain
no no yeah they have like I've traveled
quite a bit in Spain but not there yeah
yeah it's on the North Coast it's like
most Michelin star restaurants or
something like that get very excited
about that so um anyway enough about
enough about that stuff enough about the
dreaming but you know the dreaming is
all part of life so I've been watching
your videos for a long time on YouTube
and you know you have so much content
and it's so so f for so many people
because um it it's feel like we're
living in like a very interesting time I
think it's a great time to be alive but
it can probably be very confusing for a
lot of people and I think the fact that
you have so much direct experience with
what you're teaching and what you're
helping guiding guide people through it
makes all the difference to have fully
lived it so I kind of thought it'd be
interesting instead of sort of just
diving right into like Spiritual
Awakening and all the facets of of it
because I was thinking I was like hm
what is spiritual because I'm like okay
spirituality religion and then I'm like
but what is spiritual so I thought I
would like just break it down be like
what is spiritual and what is
Awakening yeah so to me anything
spiritual really when I use the word I'm
just referring to anything non-physical
uh some you know things that you cannot
perceive with your traditional five
senses that's what I would consider
spiritual uh some would call that would
call that Quantum Quantum physicists
would probably hate us calling that
Quantum so I won't do that because they
do not no they just give it different
words it's totally the same thing like
quantum entanglement you know you're
like can you explain that and they're
like well not
really give it a cool name yes so to me
spiritual is just anything non-physical
anything that exists that cannot be
perceived with the traditional five
senses we've got more but with the
traditional five senses A Spiritual
Awakening the term that term there's
many definitions the way that I like to
look at it is a spiritual awakening is
when you whether spontaneously or
through some kind of event most commonly
through some kind of Life altering event
which is what happened to me and what
happens to so many millions of people
something happens in your life car
accident you know diagnosis near-death
experience whatever it is something
really shakes the foundation from you
and suddenly you start to think there's
got to be more to life than this and it
that question to me is what triggers A
Spiritual Awakening there has got to be
more than
this and as soon as you open that door
you know there's got to be more than
this what is there
more that gets you down into the rabbit
hole of of you know starting to
uncovering different layers
understanding really just letting the
spiritual awaken
embody in you just I I see it kind of as
these doors that just start opening you
know like Spiritual Awakening is some
sort of of passcode and then the doors
open and then you walk in and you just
keep going deeper and deeper and deeper
and and as you go more and more layers
are revealed to you you know about the
world but also about your life I think
mostly spiritual Awakenings they have
consequences outer consequences but for
any one who's within the spiritual
that's where spirituality is different
from
religion it's in the the the concept of
direct
experience so religion is more outwardly
directed so you have a book out there or
you have a priest or you have an Imam or
you have a rabbi you have some sort of
authority figure interpreting a text or
interpreting a string of
thought and in in spirituality it's all
about direct experience it's how do I
perceive Spirit how do I feel it how do
I experience it how do I experience it
there's no books are needed no you know
um books and videos and all the stuff
that we do is helpful but it's not
really needed in the true true sense of
what of what spirituality is you know
it's a very inward focused Journey yeah
well said that's so true talk about that
ineffability because it's re it really
does feel like that there when you have
a spiritual experience or like I'd be
curious to talk about plant medicine if
that's been a part of your practice or
your world it's ineffable and there's
and to me that those things help with
the embodiment because until I actually
have a visceral experience it's just
thoughts you know it's kind of just the
Matrix still but embody means oh God now
this is literally is it's the isness of
things it's like no like you you know
yes the trees are alive because they've
talked to me you know yeah yeah and it
takes it takes a while sometimes you
know to to me it takes practice practice
and really trusting yourself Beyond
those five senses the the brain is so
wired for those five senses the brain is
wired to perceive the outside world the
out part of the outside world I mean not
just not just extremely limited sliver
of reality at it as it exists but even
that reality bombards the brain every
day
but only a minute amount of that sensory
information actually reaches conscious
awareness so the brain is not just a
perceiver the brain is a master filter
of reality and it needs to be because
otherwise we'd go insane right if I were
sitting in a cafe eating lunch and I
could hear my own chewing and I could
hear every single person in the cafe
talking and I could hear my friend
talking in front of me I would go insane
so the brain really does need to be a
master filtering organ nothing wrong
with that um
but the the experience of you really
needing to practice Beyond those five
senses is nobody could do it for you
it's such a direct direct experience
that you have to feel in your body and
there's an example that's coming to mind
right now when I started you know I had
a a um spiritual a Awakening in 2013
2014 I had a spontaneous Kundalini
Awakening which I didn't even know what
the hell was happening to me when I had
a Kundalini awak wening I didn't have a
guru I wasn't practicing Kundalini Yoga
I had no idea what the heck Kundalini
was and I was just sitting in meditation
and I felt the snap in my in my spine
and up comes Kundalini and I have no
idea what's going on my body started to
move and very involuntary movements and
I'm a clinician by training so my
clinical mind immediately started wait a
minute these are voluntary muscles I
should be able to control my body let me
try and stop it and as soon as I tried
to stop the involuntary move movements I
thought my body was going to snap in
half and I very quickly said let's not
do that so I just kind of let myself
move in this kind of wave pattern and so
that was you know kind of one of the
many phases of my Spiritual Awakening
that lasted about six years that main
Spiritual Awakening and I remember that
after that I started to perceive and
sense the spiritual World very quickly
very easily and one of the things that I
was perceiving I was receiving messages
and I could directly Channel I could
hear not with your ears so hard to
explain this it it's so hard to explain
it's annoying right like it's like
telepathy like it lands in the mind and
you just know it like it's like and
there's no time lapse it's not like it's
not in linear time like it is here where
it's like I am talking to you here is
what you're feeling you arrive with the
whole like the whole thing comes to you
right like yeah and it and it to me to
me it was hard at the at the time
because I was you know again clinical
mind I started channeling and I remember
that it was sort of automatic channeling
so I was speaking although it wasn't me
so I remembered I had the intuition one
day to grab a recorder and start
recording myself oh my God and yeah it
was super scary it was a super scary
time in my
life yeah and I I started kind of cool
but I sound like
psycho yeah exactly so I started to
record the sessions because I didn't
really remember much afterwards once it
finished
so I did this for a while and then I
remember my mind was just freaking out
I'm like okay every day I'd sit in
meditation and I'd say well it's quite
possible that I'm schizophrenic I'm
having a psychotic break it's not common
to be diagnosed so late with
schizophrenia but it's so all these
things are going through my mind and I
was really getting stressed and I
remember asking my guides you know I
need proof I really at this moment in my
life I need proof in the 3D physical
reality for me to be able to trust that
what I am receiving is correct and I'm
not going insane and I remember I one of
the the entities or the spirits that I
was channeling was a little girl she was
like around
four and I remember I came to um I went
traveling and I was sitting in a park
here in Portugal and um and I was
sitting there and and this little girl
passed right by me with her Grandpa
looks like looked like her grandfather
an older man and they went to the Little
Pond and I just looked at her and
thought wow she she looks like just like
the little girl that I Channel she's
littley
old yeah and I remember looking at her
thinking wow she looks just like her and
they went off and I just continued my
day and I'm sitting on the grass and
pretty soon I I look ahead and I see
this little girl coming up to me and she
literally came up to me and she just
stood in front of me and she had
something behind her back and she just
pulled it and it was like a little wildf
flower that she had caught in the park
and she just gave it to me and I
and and her and meanwhile I look over
and her grandfather this older man that
was with her is looking at her like what
the hell are you doing you know like
what are you doing and he kind of called
her and she didn't really listen to him
she was just focused on me and and she
just gave she didn't say a thing and I
said thank you I I think I said
something like thank you princess in
Portuguese and she just said you're
welcome and she left and that was it
that was the interaction that's all you
needed and and it was incredible because
right before I left on this trip I asked
for this specific guide to materialize
physically wow yeah yeah and so and
that's how powerful you know now of
course few more years into the spiritual
awakening and and more that I discovered
children are very sensitive to Spirit so
it's very easy for a spirit to go up to
a child's ear and say hey go give go
give that woman a flower or something
yeah and they'll do it they don't
question but at that moment it was so
important for me to be able to feel that
what was happening to me what I was
experiencing was not a psychotic break I
wasn't crazy I was actually tapping into
an altered state of consciousness and
that's what it felt in my body and I had
to trust that and so this you know
long-winded story to show that there's
no way to be able to train that in you
other than through direct experience you
have to feel the particularities of of
what it feels like to connect to Spirit
to connect to the other side you know to
connect to the physical and sometimes
it's hard you know I work with so many
clients who have a lot of difficulties
trusting their intuition because they
don't even know what the heck intuition
is and so we kind of have to start from
scratch like what is intuition what is
intuition to me intuition is a bit
different from how it is studied
scientifically so intuition is studied
scientifically as a subconscious
phenomenon because we're still very mind
dominant um and so even intuition
studied in the scientific Community
right now is as a mind phenomenon I
don't view intuition at all as a mind
phenomenon I view it as a heart
phenomenon and this is in line with with
uh the pretty much every chamonic
tradition on the planet if you if you go
back far enough they all talk about
heart intelligence and how your heart is
this incredible compass and that's where
that's where that initial intuitive ping
comes into it comes to your heart um
your heart has its own little mini brain
it has its own you
know dozens of thousands of neurons are
located in in your heart they look like
neurons although they're outside of the
brain so the heart has its own mind and
its own Consciousness and it receives
that first intuitive ping these neurites
these sensory neurites as they're called
in the heart receive that first
intuitive ping and the heart is
incredible at receiving that ping from
wherever it's coming from sometimes it's
your higher self which is a component of
you that exists outside of time space so
it is you but it's not it's you beyond
the human you um sometimes intuition can
come through uh guidance from other uh
Guides of yours so intuition can hit the
heart in various forms it can be your
own inner knowing too but it always
pings initially at the heart and from
the heart then it goes up to the brain
for interpretation so that but that
initial ping is what's it's so important
for people to know that that initial
ping comes into the heart because then
you'll be able to know that moment and
everybody can sense it when they've had
a clear intuitive ping because there is
no mental involvement
whatsoever no mental involvement at all
it's just bling I need to do that yeah
oh why do I need to do that I have no
idea is that like when you ask somebody
like do you think you should quit your
job or something like ask them a big
question right do you think you're in
the right relationship and they kind of
have like an like don't delay just
answer first is it like that brain is
the first answer it's the one without
the Mind interference and it like is
that the pain you're talking about or is
it more of a body feeling where you get
like your gut feels uncomfortable or you
feel anxiety or you feel tense or you
feel opening like is it more of a body
thing or is it more of like first
instinct pure intuition that comes into
the heart that pings at the heart is
emotionally neutral so that's a great
way to spot a gen intuitive ping that
has not been interpreted by the brain
yet it's emotionally
neutral so it's clear it's
likeing there's no there's no fear
there's no there's no excessive emotion
because that information has not gone up
to the brain to be processed and then
creates a story and then creates
emotions so it's very very clear yeah
it's a feeling you can even you can call
it that it's a feeling and it's a it's a
clarity it's a pull your body definitely
feels a pull to do that and it's a pull
that no matter what your emotions tell
you or what your thoughts tell you it'll
keep going and the common example I have
of this is I work with many women who
are exiting relationships or have exited
relationships because they have had a
spiritual awakening the partner hasn't
and there's this complete just you know
parting of ways right the timeline split
uh you cannot force anyone into a
spiritual awakening you can't drag them
along with you and so there's a lot
especially a lot of women I work mostly
with women that are exiting
relationships right now and it's really
interesting because I'll work with them
for a while and I'll say you know so how
are you feeling oh I you know I know
that this relationship is ending but I
haven't received yet that ping or that
clear as to when and then suddenly one
day they say okay it's now and I'm like
well what happened I don't know I just
woke up I sat up in my bed and I knew it
was today or I knew it was going to
happen soon and what is that what what
what happened it's them trusting the
timing of the universe and also the
timing of their own soul knowing when
things need to be done at what time and
at what pace and that Clarity that
Clarity it can't be rushed you know
sometimes people say that intuition is
that first thought that you have or the
first answer that you give I don't know
that I agree with that um I don't know
that I agree with that because your
subconscious mind also operates
extraordinarily quickly and so it's it's
it the subconscious mind is out
mindboggling actually because the
subconscious mind is already answering
before you have before your conscious
mind has finished
listening isn't that insane like that is
so insane the subconscious mind is
already answering before my ears have
finished listening or my conscious mind
has finished interpreting what my ears
are listening to got to be picking up a
frequency then it like if you're if you
start to communicate something and
you're I'm telling you something I'm
coming from a place so I don't even need
to finish because there's a frequency
with my information and you can tell if
it's true or not you can tell if it's
you know you can there's a lot in there
I I'm a really very fascinated by
frequency and I think it directs pretty
much all of our experiences but that
that would plug in to make sense there
absolutely absolutely and so what I what
I usually tell people is especially
there's a there's a little side note
here and it this is especially true with
people that have suffered trauma and
that have still trauma embodied in their
body which is pretty much all of us
right like all of us if if you listen to
anything that Dr Gabor mate talks about
it's it's that literally everyone is
traumatized in this world and we just
have not been able to to give words to
what trauma actually is we all think
it's just something has to be something
like related to war or related to
something really big a car crash or
traumatic and obvious but it doesn't it
doesn't because trauma is subjective to
the experience of the person and
especially if you have experienced
trauma your body is hyper sensitive to
stimuli it's already on edge it's on
edge because there are things that have
not been healed it's not calm calm the
nervous system is not completely calm
and in order for you to tap into
intuition You' have got to have a calm
body pure intuition requires a calm body
because how are you how are you going to
receive that subtleness of the spirit
world if you yeah if you are freaking
out or if you're Restless or if you're
stressed or if your mind's buzzing and
so what I tell people is you know
there's no hurry you don't have to
answer that question right away sit with
it breathe in into it calm your body
into it and so what that does is it
removes any kind of trauma response that
the brain may have wanting to Fire and
answer
quickly you know like going back to the
relationship one um you know you're in a
toxic relationship do you want to leave
this
relationship well you know he's a really
good guy and he has good days and I
think I'm learning some lessons what is
this is this intuition this is not
intuition but she answered that really
quickly this you know fictional person
that I just made up answered that really
quickly well it's not intuition sit with
it sit with
it breathe into it really contemplate
there's no rush with intuition you don't
have to get everything done right now
you know like this all of us templated
with this excessive masculine energy
especially as Americans you know like
gotta go go go do do do hustle hustle
hustle and this really prevents us from
from breathing in and slowing down and
and really connecting to that part of us
that needs to receive that intuition and
it it we don't need to be in a rush you
know I feel that like I feel that with
even small things like um a decision to
do something or to uh book something I
want to do or like I have felt into
you're giving words to something that
I've um been experiencing more and more
which is and giving and and being more
at peace with which I am that go go go
like literally drove hundreds of miles
an hour like I I have lived a very like
regimented fast-paced masculine life and
so what I want to explain is like this
feeling of when I'm ready when that ping
happens when okay now then it goes
really easily like and it seems like
it's right on time meaning like if I
would have done it earlier I wouldn't
have had all the information to do a
good job with it or you know maybe the
puzzle pieces fit better now or you know
maybe something popped up that I should
be doing instead and I'm glad I didn't
plan that because I would have felt bad
or I would have had to cancel or I would
have said no to the other thing that I
needed to do like it comes in a lot of
ways not just even relationships or
really really emotional things but just
like the planning of life does that does
that feel like it makes sense absolutely
absolutely and especially you know like
especially for you in your life and your
career and where you're coming from it's
pretty funny because it's like you are
literally learning how to slow down from
racing right like isn't that incredible
I had no idea how fast I did everything
I I didn't I I know it sounds so stupid
but um it's everything I think fast I
walk fast I drive fast I move fast I
make decisions fast I there's nothing I
I cook fast like I there's nothing I
don't do that I don't do fast and so
it's an ironic challenge in my life I
live a lot of Duality but you but you
but you moving fast it's not necessarily
negative right like it's it's a part of
your energy the question is always
balanced like when where am I at my
natural speed and maybe your natural
speed is way faster than than most
people you know like maybe that is your
natural speed but then again here comes
the feeling it's the feeling of I went
too fast for my normal speed even for my
normal speed that was too fast and I
suffered some consequences you know
maybe I was impulsive and then you know
that backfired that decision or whatever
or you know what I mean like it
backfired in the way that the Universe
never punishes you but backfire in the
sense that the Universe always says hey
you know like maybe next time you know
course correct just a tiny little bit
I've had to do that work too you know
like I'm a double Sagittarius I'm a
Sagittarius Rising love you
already are the best oh my God
Sagittarius ascendant also so I have a
lot of fire energy and so over the years
I have really had to you know balance
balance because when you have a lot of
fire energy it's wonderful but you can
also burn down the entire Forest right
like fire is great too much fire is
really bad and so you know how do I
double Aries with like everything in the
first house so I'm like Aries sun and
moon with like a stellium in the first
house including Mars which is the
masculine I like I'm all fire
too I get you girl oh my God so yeah
it's been this it's been this balance of
knowing how to slow down when you need
to slow down but also respecting your
energy and respecting your nature and
maybe you are more fiery maybe I
obviously am more fiery than many people
and that's okay because that fire energy
certainly comes in handy for a lot of
aspects of my life and so it really is
kind of this this balancing you know
just getting the right balance for you
really what life is always helping you
do that yeah I actually that brings me
to a question I'm curious about because
it's something I
find I can do it has to do with energy
but there's a lot of people that
struggle more with it and I spel I feel
like especially if they have a very
empathic nature and they really like
empathy for feelings and really take it
on but what can people do to protect
their energy because we're totally going
to get into the Awakening and like the
phases and everything but in preparation
for that how do you protect your energy
because I find that that's something
that a lot of people struggle with yeah
so the way that I teach about empaths
and sensitives is I I've I've actually
stopped using certain words that are
common in the um you know in the
community of empaths and one of the
reasons that one of the words that I
don't use anymore is protect because as
soon as you use the word protect there's
an implication that there's some kind of
weakness or fragility there that needs
to be protected you you know kind of
like an innocent little baby that you
need to protect or you know a sensitive
flower or there's some kind of
sensitivity there's some kind of
sensitivity not sensitivity in you know
like the really powerful sensitivity
that I can feel everything but
sensitivity in the in line with
fragility and so the way that and when
when you use the word protect there's
the way that I Envision that is that the
energy is encroaching on you and you
need to put up some water walls of some
sort that's what protection feels like
to me it's an energy that is
encroaching and I have to you know maybe
I need to figure out how to break the
walls down and so yeah so that
misdirects the energy in my opinion
because you when you say I need to
protect myself you are internally
telling your body that you are weak or
that you're fragile in some way and so
the way that I like to work with
sensitives and empaths myself including
I had to learn this on my own I'm an
extreme physical empath so I actually
somaticize energy in my body and so yeah
it it's it was a little trippy initially
when I was learning how to do this and
so the the way that I learned how to do
this and I work with clients now is it's
not protect it's
project so you protect yourself by quite
simply walking into a room and if you
don't like the energy you dominate the
energy you literally project your energy
out so think about it in terms of a
living fire so if I'm a walking living
fire what's going to happen if anything
comes up against me burn it down it's
literally going to burn so if I if I
walk around with that and again this
takes practice right like this is a this
is a practice that's very very
coordinated with the third chakra the
solar plexus that's your center of
personal will and power and and that's
the center of your individuality you as
a separate being in this world is
coordinated by that solar plexus that's
your sun top of the stomach right before
your sternum starts so right that top of
the stomach below your heart maybe three
inches below your heart so as soon as
your chest bone ends there's a hole
there that's where your solar plexus is
located right because it's a good good
to know where it is because there's a
lot of feelings that come into that now
people know yes oh yes that's your
center of anger so this is the fire this
is the fire chakra your Cent Center of
anger uh it's a beautiful amazing chakra
it's an unusual chakra but we can we can
talk about that in a little bit but just
to complete this thought when I I was in
New York City you know 10 million people
in Manhattan alone I lived in Manhattan
I'd go I'd go to a bar and and literally
I would always have my plan I was so
sensitive I didn't want to talk about it
I wasn't particularly spiritual at the
time and what I would do was I would
walk into a bar my friends never knew I
was doing this but I would always look
for exits so either a bathroom or
where's the exit because if I started to
feel overwhelmed I'm out of here I am
totally out of here so notice what I was
doing I was assuming that I needed to
get out of there why did I need to get
out of there because the assumption is
these people here in this bar their
energy is stronger than mine and they
are encroaching on my energy and I need
to run away so many empaths do this they
run away they run away they run away
they they say I got to go live in a
cabin in the forest because I can't
stand people and that could be true for
a very small amount of empaths but for
the majority of sensitives that are on
this planet we're actually here to
change the energy we can't do that if
we're in the middle of a forest being
afraid to confront or to stand in
certain situations and so my training
with my guides was really very simple I
walk into a room if I don't like the
energy and don't like the energy meaning
it is heavy it is dense um it it's you
know I mean think about it the energy of
a bar you know like everybody's drunk
It's invasive it's inappropriate it's
sloppy it's all of this all of this
energy if I walk into a room and I feel
that it doesn't matter if there's one
person in that room or a thousand people
in that room I will dominate the energy
in that
room and and so so do you see the
difference do you see the energy
difference here I do not need to be
protected from anything yeah at all m M
and and so that's different because now
you're projecting it's this this energy
is it's so give me out because this
really I get this resonates I I I feel
like it's I I every now and again I'll
practice it where I go in with a feeling
like I if I'm using a specific example
for myself like especially like a
feminine energy like a soft Like Loving
like osexual energy like a like if I go
in and and like it's amazing the the
magnetism that that has and the reaction
that that gets so it's like something
that I want to cultivate more because of
my past has like formed me in a way and
it served me but it's time to kind of
evolve and grow and soften and slow down
and um and so I'll go into the like I'll
I'll like arrive with that energy like
I'll be thinking about it and embodying
it and feeling it and then I just sort
of let that go is that what you mean by
projecting an energy or is it like how
do you get into the space where you can
project what you want it's a little it I
can feel the energy that that you're
that you're talking about I can feel
that energy it's an amazing delicious
energy but it's not the same it's a
specific part of your feminine energy
that's a whole other conversation it's a
specific part of oh my God you're going
my therapist after this because guess
what feminine energy is not always sweet
and soft that's what's taught what's
been taught in a very patriarchal
masculine dominant world world the
feminine is not always soft there's a
there's you know that's the mother what
I call the mother Mary facet that's the
softness that feminine has been more
accepted in our Collective for a really
long time but she is not the only one
collie have you ever worked with collie
no but my my my very dear friend who who
does ceremonies and she's like your dark
goddess your dark goddess energy and I
was like okay thank you for like
honoring a aspect of me that like is
able to channel the int like have
intuition have feelings and be able to
cut through like with like a the
sharpest knife with what needs to be
said and done yes and a lot of times
people mistaken that for masculine so
they think that masculine hard masculine
so collie is is for for your listeners
that don't know who collie is is a Hindu
goddess she is known as collie the
Destroyer so collie is an energy that
literally when you call on collie she
comes in with her sword and she is
traditionally depicted as having a sword
in her hand and she has a decapitated
head of a demon in her other hand that's
literally if you look up colie that's
what she looks like and that represents
is she slays the demons meaning all
Demons of your ego she destroys
everything in your life that's not meant
to be there that's why sometimes people
do not like to work with her because she
comes in you call collie and she's like
all right I'm going to clean it
up and that's a really do but do you see
how different that is so what you're
saying is I walk into physical spaces
and I'm holding more of a sexual maybe
even Isis energy there are so many
facets to the feminine you're gonna yeah
I work with ISIS I work with Isis Isis
Maat um not really seket but more of the
Egyptian sort of goddesses but I think
Ki needs to come in because that feels
like very close to home with what my
energy does sometimes it's necessary
sometimes it's necessary and if people
don't like to use the archetypal don't
like to talk about feminine energy in
terms of archetypes then we can always
go into the animal kingdom you know and
the the example that I love to give of
that facet of the feminine is a lioness
with her
cup so if a lioness has her cup you're
not gonna play games with
her I don't care if you're the biggest
baddest lion in the freaking serengetti
you will not try and touch her cub and
see what she does to you that's a
feminine
energy interesting because we like to
think it's a masculine energy but that
is not that's a feminine energy it's
just a different facet so feminine
energy can be very Fierce so but
following your story I want to ask you a
question so you could feel the
difference so you walk into a gr room
with this with this you know like with
your natural energy it's maybe a little
bit sexual maybe it's a little bit
flirty or whatever and that would that
would be what that would be what I
project that's not my Natural Energy but
that would be something I'm trying to
like do you want to know more about
Natural Energy let's go with it let's go
with your example so you walk into a
room with this energy and let's say
someone that you're not particularly
interested in starts hitting on
you what do you do I'd probably receive
that as like I I in that situation I
would understand and it would make sense
and I would be like almost giggling
inside like oh wow okay I did what if it
gets to a point where it's inappro rate
hitting on you I am excellent at knowing
how to exit I am very good at managing
situations and um having a lot of
bandwidth for banter okay so so feel
very comfortable I would be fine okay
cool cool so when you're that energy
that we just tapped into right there
where I said what if the hitting on you
gets to a point where it's starting to
get annoying or it's starting to get
unwan thing or or it's starting to INF
really like impose that person's energy
is imposing on you that's the energy of
the solar plexus that now needs to
project out and when you said I exit the
situation did you mean I leave or did
you mean I exit the situation as in I'm
very direct and stopping that that
energy exchange what did you mean by
exit I would know how to walk away I
would know exactly how to exit the the
the face-to-face situation okay okay and
so here's a here's a something for you
to practice next time because this will
you you then you'll understand the
difference and that solar plexus
strengthened you don't need to exit the
other person can exit what if you were
there first why would you need to exit
and that's the energy the energy that's
the energy the energy will make them
exit yes of course yes of course even
more yes you're going to make me even
more like like yeah anonomous in my like
being that makes perfect sense because
the energy doesn't lie God there was
this one time I was in Europe I was
telling you I was in Europe and there
was this guy that kept coming up to the
table and he was like wanting us to buy
something we were in Rome and
everybody's like he just was really
persistent and I just looked at him and
I
went and he walked right away because I
was like basically I'm going to
knock you down if you don't walk away
and all I did was look at him all I did
was look at him that right there that is
the answer that's that's how empaths
protect themselves what you just said
right there that is exactly what it is
you didn't need to speak a word you
didn't need to you literally stood there
and that third chacker just went big
time he didn't even say anything he just
went oh that's so cool yeah yeah yeah
and that's and and that is sometimes
hard especially for women because we are
templated to exit situations especially
if we're approached by aggressive
men because it's always on us to exit
it's always on us to get ourselves out
of sticky
situations and what this does is hey
buddy if it's a man that's
inappropriately hitting on you hey buddy
inappropriate not
interested thanks you know I'm just
going to continue drinking my drink you
can go off your Merry way or you can go
in that direction you were walking in
that direction you can keep going so
that's so cool to try like for those
listening that find themselves in
situations that they're not they don't
appreciate or like or something like or
they want a different energy to just
like feel it for yourself and see if you
get the
reciprocation or not that's not right if
you get the reaction in you get the
right reaction to your energy if it's a
leave energy see if they leave if it's a
if it's a you know open up like like you
know be a little bit more open and
vulnerable like see if that does it like
if you want something a little bit more
sweet and sultry or sexy you know oh
that's such a great test like that's
such a great spiritual test it's a
different perspective for empaths and
and I think this helps shift people it
helps shift mindsets and heart sets and
energy also because people start to
understand that as extreme sensitives
they are not here to run away they're
not fragile wall flowers living in a
harsh world they're supposed to be here
and they're supposed to be here
precisely because they have enormous
Energy Systems sensitives have very big
Energy Systems very big you know the the
the quintessential example that I love
to give I was raised Catholic and I love
to I still identify very much with
Master Yeshua with Jesus uh with what
was call Christ and because his life is
so well known throughout the world I use
him as an example A lot of times because
even if you're not religious you
understand what ha you know what
happened to him and he really is the
quintessential example of sensitive is
not weak nobody looking at an image of
Jesus dying on a cross can c can say
he's fragile he knew exactly what was
going to happen to him and he kept
walking towards Jerusalem but he was
incredibly sensitive and that's why
people came by the thousands to listen
to him talk
and it was sensitivity that healed his
sensitivity just literally changed the
entire energy grid of a specific
geopolitical location within the Middle
East but also in the world right and so
imagine that's one sensitive okay a
sensitive that was a master also at the
same time but we're all exactly but one
and that means that all of us that are
sensitives we really are like
superheroes energetic
superheroes you know like and if we
learn to see ourselves that way we don't
have to peel it or run away when the
energy is too harsh or we don't have to
cower energetically we don't have to put
up walls to protect ourselves so this is
a little bit of a different perspective
but it does take training in that third
chakra to be able to project this energy
it's kind of like a heartbeat I can feel
it like a heartbeat it's this constant
boom boom and it just projects out in
front of you you know you know when you
throw a rock in a lake and it just
ripples it's that Ripple you know your
energy when you are walking around in
life your energy is Rippling in all
directions depending on your Energy
System size oh yeah this feels like
almost like a bit of a phase a later
part of the phase because it feels like
there's also this part where you have to
figure out that you are taking on other
people's energy or you are and that can
be confus confusing I think yeah I've
only experienced it a couple of times I
I and I'm curious a little bit about
anxiety too because I the my my the
three or four times I've experienced
anxiety I took on a feeling in my body
that I mean I couldn't decide if it was
mine a couple times and then like the
first two times I didn't know the second
two times I'm like I don't actually the
first time I didn't know second time I
didn't I I was I knew it wasn't mine
anyway so like half of them I was like
not mine what is this the other H the
other two times I was like I'm
overwhelmed and I have no idea what's
going on right now and so maybe like how
does someone start to have some
sovereignty over their their set point
or their emotions based on somebody
else it's it's really simple if you're
feeling it meaning let's get a little
bit more technical if you are feeling it
and it's registering in your body it's
already passing the quantum levels of
you so it's already past all layers of
your aura your electromagnetic field
it's already P the layers of the chakras
and it's already registering inside your
body in the realm of matter that's the
only part of you that's made out of
matter your meat suit so as soon as it
registers at the level of the body it
has penetrated enough that now it's
safely
yours it really is
yours and and and there are a couple of
reasons why it's so important to
understand this one is because you are
sensitive you are a living fire it means
that if it registers inside of you you
can very easily say this is mine and I
now process this in all directions of
time
immediately and there goes your living
fire so does it really matter if it came
from Joe or Mary or whatever doesn't
really matter it doesn't matter now I'll
tell you why people use the I don't know
if it's mine or if it's someone else's
very commonly people will use this as a
trick to bypass uncomfortable emotions
that they do not want to deal with
inside of them have you ever heard
anyone say is this mine or is it theirs
having to do with any positive
emotion noever
transer right nobody nobody says oh I'm
feeling so much joy I want to get rid of
this because this ain't mine I got to
figure out if this is mine nobody say
I'm a miserable person Len this is not
mine I'm not normally like this exactly
exactly so you see what I mean we only
say one and not the other yeah yeah yeah
so we only have this saying of I don't
know if it's mine or if it's theirs when
it comes to
uncomfortable emotions and feelings some
of them may indeed be coming from Joe or
Mary that you were just hanging out with
and you went to have a coffee and they
just projected all of that onto you that
may be true but again it already
registered in your system it's yours you
know process it and then move on with
your
day deal with it exactly but the
question is this Joe or Mary's or is
this something inside of me that I do
not want to see I don't want to sit with
I don't want to
acknowledge I don't want to work with
this is really
common yeah yeah really really I think
it ends up being I'll go run away to the
woods oh yeah oh yeah I'll go run away
with the wood to the woods because now
I'm not surrounded by all these pesky
people with their with their dense
energy guess what you're going to go
into the woods and if that was yours and
only yours you're still going to feel it
yeah you are still going to feel it you
may feel it less for a little bit
because the natural world is amazing at
making us feel better and just really
helping in all ways the natural world
animals and plants they're not great
mirrors because they are so
unconditionally loving you're not going
to get a mirror out of them you are not
going to get a mirror you're not going
to get a dog coming up to you and being
nasty one day you're not like they they
just animals and plants just love us
unconditionally so they're not great
mirrors they are just great juicy
unconditionally loving energy that just
like a warm blanket when I say mirrors I
mean we need mirrors in the 3D reality
to show us the work that we need to do
within us because we cannot see these
These Eyes these eyes are great at
looking out these eyes are not great at
looking in and so that's where the
mirrors come in usually in the form of
Human Relationships you know I was just
having this conversation yesterday with
someone about um the mirrors that are
all around us but um it was actually
with Nicole laa have you heard for the
holistic psychologist yes yes yes yes I
love her
why is it that it's in our romantic
Intimate Relationships that they do the
most work why is that we can get it from
our friends and our family and things
like that right but like like family can
get pretty close but you know heartbreak
and like relationships that what is it
about that relationship that makes it so
powerful for the mirror to show us
something that's oh my God this is a
this is a whole this is a conversation
that could last us forever there are a
couple of things going on one of them if
you are talking about a genuine Soul
heart-c centered connection that's a
connection that is primarily the
connection is at your heart with the
other person so mediums who can see
energy can actually see these
connections by these beautiful chords
that are established there's a
connection between your hearts these are
what I call Soul connections so these
are genuine pure very high vibration
connections then we've got the
connections where you cord in your lower
chakras these are what some spiritual
teachers call karmic
connections these are connections that
come into your life to teach you lessons
you don't have a heart cord with them
where's the twinflame cord I was going
to ask you about just said soul and
karmic and the other one's twin flame so
if you want to include that in the is it
like an entire body
rope I stopped uh I I stopped using the
term twinflame because it's so much
baggage associated with it andc
primarily because I started working with
many many clients who thought they were
in a twinflame connection and they were
in a karmic connection and they were
just being abused and they were in just
horribly toxic relationships and because
of this stupid label called twin flame
they kept staying there and just being
miserable so I stopped using that term
uh but I do still have older videos uh
on the twinflame connection I've watched
all I look back looking back at like I
was looking back at all the those are
old I know well I've looked like in my
research I go like look at the newest
stuff you've done I look at the oldest
stuff you've done and I look at the most
like highly rated stuff on YouTube and
um as I'm scrolling through the various
different sort of like ways to look at
things I was like oh yeah phase like
part one oh yeah part two I watched that
part three I watched that too I don't
even remember when but I've watched them
all yeah and and but that's that's
really the reason why I stopped calling
it a twin flame so yeah makesense I mean
it's like seems like something you want
you're like oh this seems so rare why
would I let this go it seems so special
don't they know like oh it's supposed to
be hard there's it it seems like
something you should want or like
valuable in a way and magical maybe and
really I think you know it's probably a
very good idea to like because language
is important language is important and
at the end of the day the label doesn't
matter that's what I have learned over
the years the label doesn't matter
because what what happens with a
twinflame connection or a very sacred
Soul connection is yes on a vibrational
sense you are like two PS in a pot you
know like some people say you're the
same soul split in two bodies I you know
like that's not how it has been shown to
me but suffice it to say that you and
that person have a an incredible energy
resonance you're like two pieces of the
same puzzle and you just fit together
you you are those two pieces that fit
together
energetically but here's where things
get complex you can be someone's twin
flame and on a 3D human level they are
not in any way shape or form ready for
any type of relationship with you and at
the end of the day we are in human form
here to experience a human existence and
so if you have Joe in your house I don't
care if he's your twin flame if he is
treating you like day in and day
out what does that say about the work
that you have to do within
yourself and so that's why the label
doesn't even matter because I ask people
more simple questions are you well
treated are you respected are you ch is
in this connection even when things get
really difficult really really difficult
are you having vulnerable conversations
are you having adult conversations do
you have your three chakras the three
lower chakras um healed have you been
doing work on that because if you are in
this world to have a sacred connection
of that magnitude whether it's a
twinflame a soulmate whatever you want
to call it if you are in on this planet
to have a sacred Soul relationship with
someone you better damn be certain that
those three lower chakras are worked on
because otherwise you are going to mess
it
up and why the three lower chakras first
chakra that is the that chakra is the
first one to come online in your
mother's womb that is the chakra of here
I am on this planet I deserve to be here
I am on this planet it's that that
chakra of security of stability found
ational security second chakra super
important chakra not just sexual a lot
of people talk about it as the sexual
chakra it is it's also the chakra of
bonding if your second chakra is messed
up you will bond inappropriately to
Partners this is where the co-dependent
childlike type of you know oh my God
he's talking to a cute girl I'm so
jealous second chakra you see like all
of the this and then third chakra we've
already talked about this is me you know
I am really powerful unique amazing
being and I deserve to be here and I
also set the rules of engagement on what
I accept and how I accept to be treated
and how I want to be treated I'm GNA say
those Rules of Engagement really clearly
and if Joe or yeah oh yeah if Joe or
Mary don't understand them then
hi you know so at the end of the day
does it really matter if it's a
twinflame or not it doesn't the the the
labeling doesn't matter the the mirrors
though are intense absolutely intense
and one of the reasons why that mirror
is intense going back to your original
question of why the the genuine Soul
connections are mirrors because that
person is literally like staring at
yourself and that could be really
blinding especially if you don't want to
see certain aspects of
yourself imagine you don't want to see
certain aspects of yourself and then
those aspects are just staring you in
the face every day intense intense
mirror because again that person is like
you in another body people can that's an
easier way sometimes of thinking about
it think about yourself in another body
looking back at you yeah it's it's like
there's a lot of things that I always
feel like I have to like be able to like
really picture it and really feel it and
that's it's it's like it's a lot because
it it breaks the it it's doesn't follow
um it doesn't follow science it doesn't
follow biology or logic you know it's
and and that that mirror you looking at
yourself that's the the sacred mirror of
a sacred connection not only are you
looking at yourself but that colle
connection is very close to you it's
very close to that heart center the
closer the connection is to your heart
the more it will
mirror
so even my mom my dad my brother my
friend my whatever they're they're still
at a little bit I can love them very
deeply but there's a little bit of a
distance here a romantic connection
comes in very very very deep into this
heart chakra can the sacred type the
karmic connection comes very close
mostly because of of chords that are
established in those three lower chakras
and I don't know if you've ever been in
one of these connections but it's the
connection of oh my God I'm in love and
I'm G to spend the rest of my life with
this person oh my God and then a month
later it
implodes you know you you kind of like
also then have to talk about the aspect
of narcissism and like like I think that
can get very confusing because that that
has a similar feeling where it's like
boom and it's very explosive and it's
sudden and it's the huge and you know
you're soulmates as you think or you're
like you know meant to be and where have
you been my whole life and then all of a
sudden you're like what happened um you
know it it gets very confusing to know
sort of the difference between all those
things even it doesn't even matter right
because it's just the feeling that's
what you're trying to say who cares if
it's narcissist who cares if it's karmic
who cares if it's twinflame it doesn't
matter yeah how's it going and at the
end of the day at the end of the day the
the the narcissist piece sometimes plays
I like to talk about the the the
chemistry the spiritual chemistry of
what's actually going on in a karmic
connection because people will say to me
how the hell did I get into this like
literally how did I get into this you
know CU now looking back there was so
many red flags so many red flags so many
red flags and now I look back and I'm
like what but at the time what was
happening it's really cool that the soul
does this this is this is insane and
very cool so your soul establishes
various possible karmic contracts down
here before you incarnate because the
soul knows that those are very good
teachers very good teachers karmic
connections and so let's say you're
going about your life and your Soul's
like H you there's one lesson you have
not integrated all right here we go
let's call on karmic number one and then
comes karmic number one now look at what
happens do you think that if your
intuition and your inner knowing and
your heart chakra were working properly
you would let that karmic come near
you you would no because you can feel
the like you're because when time and
space is not part of your reality you
know this isn't working yeah yeah so
won't be a match like I would think that
if you knew and not a match you're a
match if they're there they're a match
to you which is temporarily kind of the
sad partar temporarily hopefully
temporarily I know I know that's
actually a good point because some
people can't stay with kics their whole
lives yeah but the the spiritual the
energy aspect is really interesting the
karmic comes near you and what your soul
does is your soul temporarily veils your
intuition that's wild isn't it your soul
will temporarily Veil your intuition and
this is why people say I look back on
that and it's like it's like I was in la
la land I I I was I was living in this
parallel reality and I don't know how I
did not see this but at the moment it
felt like genuine love I was so in love
with this person your intuition has been
veiled and then the three lower chakras
get corded by the karma
oh and so now you're CED at those lower
chakras especially the
second you're corded and now you're
bonding but because you probably didn't
have really good examples in your
parents the first examples you had of a
relationship ship where your parents and
the majority of us have had you know
like very few of us have had that
beautiful ascended parent relationship
with each other a lot of us have the
first examples that we have love yes
very common so now that second chakra is
programmed with Mommy and Daddy or mommy
and mommy or daddy and daddy my
caretakers
relationships and I program that in my
second chakra and if it was a
codependent immature love I'm now going
to bond with this karmic in that way and
woohoo we're going to feel like we're
really in love until hits the fan
because it always will with a karmic
that karmic is in your life to teach you
lessons and to help you heal if you see
those wounds and then eventually then
what happens you learn the lessons
you're doing the work and then the Soul
goes yeah okay she's or he's ready and
it pulls the the the veil out of your
intuition yep and then suddenly you wake
up and you look at that person next to
you and you're like I need to get the
hell out of here like this is so clear I
have no idea how I'm still with this
person I'm almost a bit disgusted by
this yeah yeah what was I thinking what
was happening and it's a little bit of
an aha moment and I've worked with so
many people that go through this phase
where they're like they know they just
know it's just that knowing you may not
be ready to follow through on the
knowing yet but you know that that is
not the right person for you what happen
when you don't leave they leave you and
you can't get over them oh my God
sometimes they will leave you because
obviously these are two beings that are
interacting and maybe they for whatever
reason their soul or their body is
finished with the interaction and they
move away even that is a lesson even
that is a lesson that's an important
mirror wait a minute someone that was
treating me like walked away from
me and I can't get over
them let's review this again some
someone that treated me like walks
away from me and I can't get over them I
should be over the moon freaking
screaming thanking the universe to
please have exited that person yeah the
the I the universe says like I heard
conversations that you didn't the
universe you know exactly but what is
that showing you so many bonding wounds
so many abandonment wounds the primary
bonding wound there is again I bonded
with this person as a child I have
established a parent child relationship
with is very common in adult
relationships unfortunately so if mommy
or daddy or whoever walks away the child
is left like in this state of anxiety
right if you leave your child somewhere
and you just walk away they're going to
freak out that's literally what's going
on inside of you because you were
relating to this child as a child it's
survival like they literally that's how
you have a roof over your head food on
the table like it is survival so when
they leave you are dying because they
you identify them as a parent or from
those sort of like bonding chakras where
you that it it feels like that yeah yeah
and so then what ends up happening is if
the person gets it you know let's say
let's say we're talking you know I'm I'm
assuming all of your audience is
spiritually awakened right you talk
about these amazing topics so if the
person
that person exits and they immediately
start to do a review because you should
be doing a review of your relation as
soon as your relationships fall apart
get a journal out and please start
reviewing because if you don't review
and correct and learn the lessons Joe
Schmo is gonna show up right in front of
you again in the form of someone else
same different
day absolutely will happen so I always
tell people please review um and so if
you start to do that take stock of that
connection you start to realize wow you
know like I related in a really immature
way I was allowed I was allowed to be uh
treated poorly I was treated like
crap
child yeah and so then there comes the
work and if you focus on those three
chakras for anyone anyone who is having
difficulty disconnecting from an
unhealthy relationship three lower
chakras must be your focus particular
focus on the second one for people that
are on their own and they're like look I
I have this this shit's hitting home I
know I probably need to do three lower
these lower chakras three lower
chakras uh always always start in the
staircase mode the chakras develop one
after the other like like uh the rungs
of a staircase so you can't work a lot
of times the the mistake that's been
made in spirituality
is to everybody wants to focus on the
upper chakras because everybody wants to
be the P
gland crystals and connect with the E
exactly and meanwhile I say to people
can you please be careful because if you
start focusing too much up here and your
lower chakras are not grounded you're
going to be like a big tree without
roots guess what's going to happen to
you you're going to Tumble
over yeah exactly and then people start
to hallucinate and be go crazy and say
they're seeing demons and they're seeing
God knows what why because you are not
grounded this might be really good
recommendation for people that want to
do plant medicine to start with the
lower chakras first oh my right like if
you could weave some of it about because
it sounded like maybe you've done some
of that like I work with aasa and let me
tell you if I had not done grounding
work you know like plant medicine is
incredible plant medicine is very
powerful plant medicine has to be used
with a tremendous amount of respect oh
yeah and with a tremendous amount of
inner work prior to using these plants
that's my recommendation on that but
going back to your to to the chakras
lower chakras start with the first then
move to the second then move to the
third you can't correct an upper chakra
without the lower ones being corrected
because they develop in a staircase so
the first one develops in utero so by
the time you pop out your first chakr is
already fully functional and then it
goes up as you're as you're you're going
into your Todd into the four five then
you go up to the second chakra and now
you're bonding with your caretakers and
then you get to the pre-adolescent stage
and that's where that third chakra comes
in your sovereignty and you start to say
I want to wear I want to go all Goth I
want to wear these you know this is me
that phase of that pre-adolescence when
they come into their skin and they're
trying to establish their own identity
that's the development of the third
chakra and so if you're 40 or 45 and and
you're like well I've already passed
those ages so how do I go back you just
you don't follow it by physical age you
follow it simply by that going to right
to the root first chakra doing some work
on the first chakra under grounding
grounding grounding grounding grounding
grounding in any way that you possibly
can then to the second chakra bonding
bonding bonding how do you bond with
others and usually what I tell people is
forget the sexual part of the second
chakra because that's a more advanced
use of the second chakra the more basic
use of the second chakra is bonding how
do I bond with others do I bond in a
healthy way or do I bond in this really
anxious attache kind of way you know
where like if someone stops talking to
me I immediately start to feel nervous
and I want to text them right away did I
do wrong yes yes yes people understand
this energy it's that Restless energy
that if someone changes their behavior
you start to freak out that's a really
unstable second chakra really childish
and unstable second chakra and so we go
to the second chakra and then we move up
to the third and some of the exercises
that we talked about today about
projecting your energy out being
confident I I do this every morning I uh
I stand in front of my window one of my
windows faces sunrise and as the sun's
coming up I just do a prayer slm
meditation SL intention and I just
literally reach above and I call for
Father God energy masculine coming from
above down and I ask that energy to
imbue my lower chakras with
self-confidence and power the power of
the masculine energy and then I go down
to the floor and I call feminine energy
mother God energy from the bottom up my
body up my body also imbuing me with the
same
energy self-confidence power but of the
feminine facet and then I asked them to
join at the heart
do this every day I love this practice I
love love love this practice and and you
know there's so many others that you can
do for those three lower chakras and if
people you know people want to check out
my videos I have a bunch of videos on
Lower chakras and solar plexus and all
of that and that's how you
start is there any correlation between
the
chakras what those lower three being
what we're sort of like living with here
on Earth it's kind of our
experience and the dimensions and how
this is sort of like 3D and you
transition quickly through four to five
and then it ascends right is there any
correlation to the dimensions or not
it's just an idea some somewhat somewhat
um what I like to correlate the chakras
mostly with is with uh levels of
consciousness which you could say are
exactly the same thing
if we're trying to evolve and grow and
like expand our Consciousness and
transcend to a different reality then we
can't be stuck down here yes yes yes we
go through the heart we have to go
through the heart and we have to ascend
past those but essentially meaning that
you know the planet needs to heal we
need to heal those lower three chakras
before we can fully Ascend as as a
planet absolutely and and again if you
just follow the the theory of the lad a
little step one step at a time then
everything works out perfectly wonderful
for you not wonderful in the sense that
you know bad things won't happen to you
anymore because that's impossible down
here but wonderful in the sense that now
you're really starting to develop your
energy appropriately and balanced really
really balanced and it's starting from
those lower three chakras yeah you're
correct each chakra has a level of
consci ious so you can think about them
almost like mini brains uh in Hindu
Hinduism talks about chakras as Wheels I
don't see them as Wheels I see them as
floating Suns that's how they appear to
me and so if you think about a chakra
like a little mini
brain with a personality each chakra has
a personality in a different level of
Consciousness the higher you go up on
these chakras the higher the level of
Consciousness until you get to the heart
and I know this is
controversial because uh our coming the
the the knowledge base coming from the
East is saying that higher
better and I identify more with shamanic
tradition which is Middle better
heart so to me the heart is the most
evolved of all of all of our seven main
chakras which is really interesting so
it's like the chakras go like this
almost like the masculine feminine I
look at so many things in like a fractal
um parallel nature like there's just so
many ways that things apply and like
you're able to Overlay so much and go oh
this is kind of like this this is kind
of like this it's almost like that's the
masculine coming to the heart and The
Feminine getting out of the ethers and
coming down into the heart and meeting
for like this alchemical marriage of the
of
yourself yes and the heart is the great
connector the heart is where everything
integrates so think about it if I have a
does it really matter if I have this
amaz an example sad example we've all
seen examples of gurus this is happened
especially with men that then sexually
abuse their
followers how does this happen if these
beings are extremely evolved well some
people say Well they're not really
extremely invol evolved but they are in
some respects some of these Masters or
gurus have
extremely developed upper chakras
extremely developed this is why they can
access psychic abilities they can access
all of this their lower chakras are
horribly imbalanced and that's why they
are immoral and
unethical and so what the heart does
that's where everything integrates so
the heart says oh yeah right look
psychic abilities that's amazing but
psychic abilities by themselves create
really horrible people so we need
psychic abilities with the grounding of
Mother Earth with the information that
I'm getting from the lower chakras we
need psychic abilities but we also need
a sense of self from the third chakra
and a sense of bonding from the second
chakra and then everything gets to the
heart and it's integrated things psychic
doesn't make you a good person at all at
all at all you know like it exactly it
makes you can be very powerful and and
this is what I tell people all the time
you know like if you ever encounter a
guru with highly developed upper chakras
and poor lower chakras run the other way
very quickly right no more than having
grounded lower chakras makes you psychic
that doesn't either that doesn't mean
that doesn't mean you are so yeah just
having the lower chakras is not going to
help you either because then this is a
person that can't access their intuition
they can't access the spirit realm so
it's it's almost like they're half dead
they're really really stuck in this
Earth plane and they cannot access the
other side this is someone this is the
Other Extreme where the person may have
really solid lower chakras but then the
uppers are are not there you know so
it's it's got to be it's the heart it's
got to be a balance and an integration
of all of it what do you think our our
our purpose here is um as human beings
going through this life and what's the
point of it and what if we had a call to
action in this experience what would it
be we're all here we all have different
missions and different purposes at any
specific lifetime this is a very prized
reality to Incarnate there billions and
bazillions of souls waiting to Incarnate
in this reality and the reason is this
this reality of matter is rare a
physical matter no wonder why we can't
find the alien there we just can't see
them exactly exactly so the the the the
uh reality of physical matter is
delicious for the soul because there is
such a huge difference between the
ethers where that soul is and then the
Soul having to descend its vibration
descend descend descend descend to come
into a physical form that is such a
profound difference in vibration and the
soul loves this the soul loves to evolve
in this way because this this reality of
matter reality of Duality white black up
down hot cold this is a really important
form of the Soul being able to evolve
now in this reality of course the soul
has to descend so many levels of
consciousness to come into physical body
and then we are born with an ego that
Shields us from who we really are the
veil of forgetfulness it's one of the
features of this reality when you
incarnate in a reality you have to you
have to follow the rules of that reality
one of the rules of this reality is the
veil of forgetfulness the majority of
people that incarnate don't remember
their past lives they don't remember who
they are they don't know who they are
they think go boom here I am I just you
know I was born and that's it really
strong veil of forgetfulness that is
important for the Soul's continued
Evolutions right because if you knew it
wouldn't be a lesson if you knew you
wouldn't be sad you'd be like it doesn't
matter we live forever or like oh I see
the dynamic we're just learning lessons
it's cool like your soul is a badass you
know like you'd never worry nothing
would happen yeah yeah and and
unfortunately in a reality of this
density and in a reality with so many
Egos and with very strong veils of
forgetfulness there's a lot of horrible
things that can happen down here in the
physical
form and you know it's
it's kind of the nature of this reality
the nature of this reality is being able
to tap into really high beautiful
miraculous States Of Consciousness or
being able to tap into really low
painful horrible States Of Consciousness
and we're each creating that inside of
us you know Heaven and Earth heaven
isn't a place it's a it's a
Consciousness it's a state of
consciousness that you can access now or
not hell is not a place it's a state of
consciousness that you can access now
and a lot of people are accessing hell
right now even in physical form you know
I mean I don't know if you want to but
to speak to obviously there's so many
like gruesome murders going on right now
in um in the Middle East and um you know
it's un Unthinkable and so I think for a
lot of people we wonder why on kind of
the the big picture is that there's
Ascension of the planet occurring the
vibration is
changing vibration is changing very
quickly and we have to follow follow the
vibration of the planet and she is
ascending she's evolving she's moving
really really quickly and if we don't
follow her we can't stay here and when
there's an Ascension process occurring
there's a lot of shaking it's like um
the the example that I like to give is
like a tank of water a tank of water
that's been still for a really long time
everything settles at the bottom and the
water looks crystal
clear but then you shake it and all of
that stuff comes and then suddenly
crystal clear water is brown and you
think what the heck it was there all of
that soot all of that dirt it was all
there it was it just settled at the
bottom and that's what's happening now
like the whole planet is shaking and all
of our shadows all of our hatreds all of
our the things that we hate about each
other the things we hate about ourselves
all of the templates that we were born
with and that's what's happening in the
Middle East and literally everywhere
when we take form in this physical body
we take on templates from the countries
we are born from in the religions we are
born in the cultures we're born in the
parents we are born in and so we take on
these templates and that can be really
difficult to heal and So speaking
specifically about the Middle East
there's the the template of religion
there's the template of
geopolitics and religion religious
animosity
has really created so much violence on
this
planet so much supposed to be the most
peaceful thing right and it's created
the most amount of war and deaths I mean
this is just
templating
fortunately there are millions and ponm
millions of people that are having
spiritual Awakenings right now some of
which is happening within religious
movements which is amazing because you
cannot change religion from the out side
you can try you can push against
religion and kind of force it to
transform the best transformations in
any movement occur from within and I've
worked with many people who are still
religious and who love their religion
and they love the principles of their
religion the energy of their religion
they no longer love the
misinterpretations of their
religion and what's happening in the
Middle East has a lot to do with
misinterpretation of religion and what
it's causing you know on both sides and
we
just I you know sometimes I can't really
even watch news or watch images because
it's it's very painful for me um but
when we are veiled and when we forget
that we are all connected and that we
all all come from the same place I don't
care what religion you are we all come
from the same place and until that truth
is is really stuck inside of us until
that the truth that if I hurt another
person I am hurting
myself nothing's ever going to change
right yeah that's clearly not embodied
on any level with the people that are
able to do what they're doing to others
yeah yeah and it's and it's hard you
know like it is hard because I know that
these templates are really really strong
this these are really complex issues you
know like uh the example of the Middle
East that you brought up these are very
comp complex issues on one side uh you
know Palestinians are saying This Is Our
Land you know we were here then on the
other side Israelis are saying This Is
Our Land and again land religion these
are very strong strong templates and so
how do you come to peace with that well
those templates have to be shed find
your own land within you find your own
like home like you know that's outside
of you it's calling for a for
sovereignty instead of the solution
being outside of you like oh if we get
this piece of land everything will be
better that never is the solution the
solution is never outside of you yeah
yeah and and that's you know
unfortunately temporarily there are a
lot of people that are suffering on the
planet because of this uh you know lack
of of Consciousness and conscious
Awakening but everybody is Awakening in
one way or another you know and and a
lot of people people um unfortunately
are dying in the middle of all of this
chaos you know like this really powerful
chaotic and very painful energy and I
always tell people who work with me um
to you know never turn your eye because
some spiritual people do that like
they'll just stay in their you know I'm
going to go meditate on a rock and
connect to whatever five Fifth Dimension
and I'm going to not even there are
actually a lot of teachers that say you
know just focus on what you want and
forget everything else and ignore
everything else I'm of a different
perspective you know like I think light
workers are here to help transform the
planet and we can't transform the planet
if we just keep looking the other way
and ignoring what's actually happening
to so many million people millions of
people that feels unkind to me and that
feels like a very closed or undeveloped
heart if a person can do that you know
so to me there's a lot of bypassing
occurring in spiritual communities
especially when it comes to the harder
aspects of life you know people people
are dying really horrible deaths on this
planet and what get it's still this the
solution is still within you right
because we all awaken we're like little
lights we all start waking up and
lighting up and then suddenly the we
help the the vibration of the whole
planet and we help others but at the
same time the Awakening within it can't
get get to a point where you become
self-centered and you're just focused on
yourself and you can't see your neighbor
just fell on the floor and you just walk
right by them that's that's not an
Awakening to me either that's
bypassing so there's this balance of and
it's not easy it is not easy you know
like I I wake up and half the time I'm
like you know I really would love to be
in a little cabin in the middle of the
woods and never speak to another human
being again I would literally be so
happy I would be happy fellow int
introvert in me get
it I would be so happy with the animals
and the birds and the bees and the trees
I see nothing
exactly so part of me would love that
but then there's a strong part of me
that knows that I'm here in this
lifetime I've done that in different
lifetimes I've been the hermit I've been
the shaman at the edge of the village
that you know people would only call on
if they really needed them or whatever
I've done the solitary lifetimes and now
my soul has been very clear in the
directive that in this lifetime you're
supposed to help people being immersed
in people my guides call it living in
the Tren of life with everybody else
that's what I'm supposed to do here now
and it is not easy because your soul
came ready with that ready to be able to
yes I listened to um I went to Burning
Man have you ever been a burning man oh
my God I want to go on my bucket list
I'm gonna go good it's really really
magical there was a talk that a guy was
giving and he is a I believe he was like
a wasn't a physicist but he was more
like maybe a some kind of like he worked
with machines but he had a lot of like
um Quantum maybe he was like a Quantum
physicist he might have been a Quantum
physicist and um so there's all kinds of
very interesting people that do talks
and he was doing a talk and we were all
able to ask questions and so I asked a
question about just sort of like it
feels almost like there's like a
separation like there's you know you
can't even like I can't even understand
the way that some people think and the
way that they live and the and the
decisions that they make or the way that
they're able to be persuaded or fall
into propaganda or like not question
Authority or things you know I just it
seems so hard to understand like will
there be a split like how does it happen
that and he basically just was like
everyone chose to be here you just you
chose to be here right now this is all
an experience we all chose to be a part
of and it's
like instead of going like that's not
mine right looping back around at the
beginning of the conversation that's not
not mine is you go no no no no this is
what you came to experience like we're
all here to experience the Spectrum and
the spectrum is pretty wide right now
but that I mean you know from plant
medicine it gets even wider right like
it goes even more and there's more
information in it and there's just you
know we're getting more of that we're
finding out more we're finding out more
about ourselves and other things and
experiencing more and more of the
extremes and I thought that was like a
almost like a comforting thought of like
oh it allows you to be able to sink into
it a little bit more and go I'm here for
this yes yes it is it isn't always easy
though right right right but instead of
thinking I don't belong here you know me
especially very you know esoteric
feeling people they're like no this
isn't my Planet this isn't my home I
don't belong here it's like but you're
here exactly this isn't mine you're like
but you're feeling it so it is yours
oh
yeah all the ways that we creatively try
and bypass and justify and navigate our
way to feeling no pain right it's pretty
magical but and Powerful but can be
empowering and I think the more that you
come into your power and you really come
into your skin not not into your skin as
like a a puny small human but into your
skin your multi-dimensional skin you
know
human soul
skin then these things start to get
easier in the sense that you don't
really have to bypass anymore because
you're not afraid of anything bypassing
only occurs when I'm afraid of
confronting something or if you want to
use a less charged word I'm afraid of
seeing something within
me once you're com into your power
there's nothing really to to to be
afraid of and it's one of the the
mantras that that I said from the
beginning of my Spiritual Awakening I
give give full permission I will not
stop until every single Stone of my
inner world is turned upside down and
and and I'll just keep
going you know just keep
going like I you know speaking about
intuition is kind of one of the first
things we talked about too and I was I
tell Jen my producer I'm like I always
have a feeling about like how much I
need to prepare how much the questions
will get followed that I come up with
and or like I just knew coming into this
one I like I wasn't I was just like I
think it's just going to flow like I I
don't know there such a wide spectrum of
spirituality to go like where do I go
with this and I'm like I mean I you know
I have I do what I normally do in
preparation but I would just knew I was
like I think it's gonna I think it's
just going to be interesting we're just
gonna flow with it and exactly what we
did I mean I questions but for the most
part this like you know was one of my
favorite conversations about
spirituality that I've had and so thank
you thank so much denk I really
appreciate it
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe
button